Hello everybody, my name is Iliyan, I am working
as a software engineer for an L.A. based company
called Liferay, and today, I will talk about
HTTP 2.0 and QUIC protocols (of the very new
future), which will replace the protocol which
is currently used by Worldwide Web - HTTP
1.1.
So, first is that question - why do we need
a the new version of HTTP protocol?
What is wrong with the [current version of
the] protocol?
After all it's used by worldwide web since
1990, right?
It works pretty well, it's very simple, actually
browser sends request the server, server responds
and this is it.
Very simple, but if you check this chart which
is just for four years, you'll see that there
is not only one request, and one response,
but there are actually multiple requests and
responses - about 80‑90 for the top 100
sites according to HTTP Archive.
So, this comes to tell us that the Web has
changed drastically, it's a web platform,
it's no more platform for reading different
cross‑linked documents.
And because of that, we have to admit that
HTTP 1.1 has issues.
Those issues are so big that unfortunately
we need a new version of the protocol and
those issues are so many that I will mention
only three of them.
The first one is that it's very latency sensitive.
Right, imagine we have a server in L.A. and
our client is right here in Berlin, all those
requests should go from Berlin to L.A. and
then get back.
This is very expensive, and, latency and protocol
is very latency sensitive, right.
Apart from that, the specification is huge.
The original specification has been replaced
by ability ten different RFCs for message
syntax for semantics and content and so on.
There are optional parts, like HTTP pipelining,
which are sometimes implemented, sometimes
they are not.
And more - like buggy proxy servers, so this
is the key - latency kills and bandwidth is
not everything, if you check this chart from,
I guess, most of you are very well aware of
it already, from some point how fast is your
network is your Internet at home for daily
browsing it doesn't matter, if you have about
five megabits, it's pretty much enough.
I'm not talking about streaming or downloading
huge video files, but for daily browsing.
What matters is the round trip time.
For every 20 milliseconds, as you see, the
page loading time increases.
So, we are stuck by latency, so what could
be the solution?
It's obvious that sending one request and
returning responses is not enough, so what
could be the solution?
One possible solution could be HTTP pipelining,
right?
Since that's exactly it's purpose, instead
to send one request to the server and waiting
for the response, browser sends three or more
requests and waiting for three or more responses.
Sounds very good in theory, but unfortunately,
it's not like this, that's not the solution.
So why not?
It's not because by the specification the
server must sends it's responses in the same
order that requests were received.
So this is it.
In fact, the entire connection remains first
in and first out, and head of line blocking
can occur.
What exactly this means?
Imagine we have three questions and the first
of them requires some heavy database request
on the server, right.
The rest, the rest of those could be just
one JavaScript and one CSS file and they will
be blocked.
There are more buggy proxy servers which are
not properly implementing HTTP pipelining.
And as a result, in most browsers, HTTP pipelining
is disabled or not implemented at all.
So keeping that in mind, what could be‑‑
what could browsers do?
What can they do in order to improve the performance?
There is no other way except to achieve multiplexing
by opening multiple connections to the servers
and that's exactly what they do.
So this is the one side of the question.
The second side or the next side is that developers,
as very creative people, they implemented
a lot of workarounds, so‑called optimizations.
Most of you will be very well aware of them,
they are creating images sprites, sharding,
resolution sharding, resource inlining, concatenating
file, combo services, preloading service when
the user is idle, reducing cookie size or
even using cookie‑free domains exactly for
that purpose, using link instead @import,
to pack components into multipart documents
and so on.
In fact, a whole industry has been created
to deal with those issues, sites have been
created, performance groups in the big companies
like Google and Yahoo have been created, but
if you're a regular developer, and as soon
as you read all those guidelines, you start
looking like this ...
Why should I do all that?
Why is that needed?
And, if you also got tired of all that, then,
say welcome to HTTP 2.0 and QUIC protocols.
HTTP 2.0 which will replace 1.1 is currently
on draft 14.
It's being actively developed and not yet
finalized, it will be probably this year or
maybe the next one.
And, it's purpose or it's objective is very
simple: To fix the issues in version 1.1,
but without breaking the web.
Sounds very ambitious and this protocol is
actually based on SPDY which has been developed
by Google in 2009.
The very first draft of HTTP 2.0 version 0
was based on the latest specification of SPDY.
So, going inside to the protocol, how browsers
switches to that protocol?
There is HTTP and HTTPS, and if we switch
from HTTP we use the upgrade mechanism, however
this means a round trip.
That's why it's better to look for another
solution.
And if we switch from HTTPS to HTTP 2.0, an
Application Layer Protocol Negotiation Extension
has been used, which avoids this draw back.
The protocol has many exciting features, and
I will note some of them.
The main difference with version 1.1 is that
it's binary protocol.
It's not text one.
So, for browsers, it makes huge difference
for us, it makes that if you use telnet to
look to some server, to log in to some server
that won't be possible anymore, but because
it's binary protocol it's much easier a parser
to be created and if you are NodeJS developer,
and you want to create your own server it
will be much easier for you to create a parser
based on this binary protocol.
There won't be a need to deal with string
limited, with strings at all.
On the very low level browser and server exchange
frames and each frame belongs to a stream.
If there is a frame, which doesn't belong
to a stream, that's protocol error.
What is really important is that those streams
are multiplexed.
We have one single connection, but multiple
streams, they are multiplexed and they also
have priorities.
This is really important - as you know, every
page there are some resources which are critical
for rendering the page and there are others
which are not.
CSS [files] are critical, JavaScript could
be critical if the page requires JavaScript,
but the images usually are not.
So, now, we can balance with those different
streams.
Something which we were doing for years was
called resource inlining, now it's on the
protocol level and it's called server push.
Again, if I have a NodeJS server, I can check
if the browser allows server push and to push
my critical resources when the page is being
loaded, right, instead to put everything on
the page, and to deal with caches and something
like this.
This is what we have to emphasize: One connection
to the server that should be enough, and not
six connection per domain as most browsers
do now.
Some of them actually open more than six connections.
But, in general, this is not good for no one,
neither for the browser nor for the server.
The browser has to deal with memory, to balance
those connections and that's not good.
Now, just one connection, we go back as to
the point, as it should be.
As I said, frames - that's on the very low
level.
And this is how a frame looks like:
We want to take a look on all of this one
by one.
I will mention just two of those, the type
of the frame, and stream identifier.
Every page has stream identifier, so as I
said [if there is no stream identifier] this
would be protocol error.
There are about ten different frame types
currently in the latest draft.
Like data frame, which conveys arbitrary data
associated with a stream there are frames
which deal with headers, some of those are
related to stream priority, some of them are
related to promises, to push promises, this
is related server push.
For some of them the purpose is to reset a
stream - just abort the stream, I don't want
the see it anymore.
And those frames are grouped in streams, so
streams, by definition is logical bidirectional
sequence of frames, frames which are being
exchanged between the browser and the server.
So, one single connection can has multiple
open streams, like in this example, you may‑‑
you may see that we currently have three streams.
Stream one, stream two, and stream four.
So, there are‑‑ they all contain some
frames, and they are multiplexed.
One stream may represent an HTML page, another
stream may represent a JavaScript file or
a third one some style, but they're multiplexed
and prioritized by the browser.
So, going to priorities:
Each stream has priority, that priority is
specified by the browser and what is important
is that priority can be changed on runtime.
So, the exact order in which frames are delivered
can be further optimized.
The priorities are optional, 31 birth value,
and stream with priority 0 has the highest
priority.
Right ...
streams also have dependencies, and like in
this example we have two streams B and C which
depend on A, so if we have another stream
called D, and it just has priority, it will
have the same value as B and C, however, if
we say that D depends on A, then B and C will
start depending on the D too.
Another key part of the protocol is related
to headers, as I said, we cannot break the
web, right, this is the deal.
So, HTTP 2.0 is stateless protocol too.
Nothing has change changed here, the client
still has to send data to to the server, however,
there is a big difference:
The headers in version 2.0 are now compressed.
This is the big difference.
Just a few words about the compression, it's
stateful, it's not stateless, which means
that a single compression context for the
entire connection is used, and the algorithm
is especially designed for the protocol, it's
called HPAC because of some evil guys who
applied attacks like CRIME and BREACH, so
we have a specially designed compression algorithm
for the protocol.
Going back to what we know very well, server
push, we did that for years, nothing new here,
I guess all of you applied or embedded some
resources to the page - CSS or JavaScript
or SVG impage or what ever.
So here, this is the difference - server pre‑emptively
sends resources to a client in association
with the previous client‑initiated request.
So, I'm requesting indexed HTML on the server
side, me as JavaScript developer who works
on NodeJS server, I can push the critical
resources which are needed for the page to
be rendered, right?
Of there is, this is a trick here - the client
explicitly must allow it.
So, on the server side when we implement our
servers, we have to check if that is allowed
otherwise that could [lead] to a reset stream
or something like this.
A client cannot push, which means the browser
cannot push resources to the server - only
the server is allowed to do that .
So - very briefly, this is it.
HTTP 2 Rulez, right?
Because now as developers we have full power
to apply different kind of optimizations,
different than those which we are currently
doing, or we can apply more - we can get heuristics
from how the user behaves with the page [in
order] to push resources, to optimize our
pages in different way.
This is not the end because now we have‑‑
because the research continues.
We have another protocol, also started by
Google, research by Google, it's called QUIC.
QUIC is a natural extension of SPDY and HTTP
2.0 research, this is also multiplexing transport
protocol but there is a big difference - this
protocol runs on top of UDP, it doesn't run
on top of TCP as SPDY and HTTP 2.0 do.
This protocol runs on top of UDP.
Because it runs on top of UDP, the browsers
cannot use those out of the box features which
are available in TCP, right?
So those should be implemented on application
level.
So why should do we that?
Because it's very hard to update TCP.
It's everywhere, it's on servers, routers,
it needs years until it's being updated.
But now we can apply the results of the research,
how to improve the web on QUIC, Google applied
to their servers, applied to Chrome and now
everything is clear.
You can see how QUIC works right now in your
browser, there is a flag, you can enable it
if you want.
I actually do it to see how it's going.
So, that's not the first time when people
are trying to fix the issues of using UDP,
people haven't slept those years, and there
were already existing solutions, like, SCTP
over DTLS, that's one possible solution, those
are two different protocols.
After all SCTP provides, among other thing,
stream multiplexing, right?
DTLS provides SSL quality encryption and authentication
over UDP stream.
So why not use those protocols?
The answer is very simple, because roughly
four round trips are needed to SCTP over DTLS
connection.
You can imagine how expensive, again with
the expensive of Berlin client and L.A. server,
that's too expensive.
In contrast, the goal of QUIC is to perform
a connection establishment with zero round
trip time overhead.
This is the goal.
QUIC has all the benefits of SPDY and HTTP
2.0, but, there there is a big difference,
there is no head‑of‑line blocking in QUIC!
As you can imagine, delaying of only one packet
causes the entire set of SPDY streams to pause,
HTTP/2 streams to pause because TCP only provides
a single serialized stream interface, but
in QUIC when a single packet is lost, only
one stream is being delayed.
We can illustrate that with an image, and
here is how does it look like.
Here we have three streams, with red, green,
and blue color, and if a packet in the stream
marked with red color is being lost, the rest
two streams are not being affected.
Here we can compare how QUIC behaves versus
TCP + TLS.
For repeat connection, it's zero milliseconds
round trip time, right, for TCP plus TLS it's
200 ms.
For new connectio with QUIC it's 100ms, for
TCP + TLS it is 300 milliseconds, that's too
much.
As I sad this protocol rests on top of UDP,
so many of the out of the box features in
TCP are now not available so they have to
be implemented on the application level.
QUIC also provides encryption, which is compatible
to TLS, but with more efficient handshake.
It has replay attack and IP spoofing protection,
and it also has something very important - in
order to minimize all those round trips, which
really decreases the performance, there is
forward error correction, which means on the
price of an additional packet (for example),
we can restore a packet which has been lost,
so the server won't have to send this packet
again.
A really cool feature for us, like especially
for us who use mobile phones, if we‑‑
that the communication channels are not defined
by IP plus port, but by an ID, so, in this‑‑
in this room there is WiFi and if you leave
the WiFi and go outside of this building for
using mobile Internet, that one‑‑ that
won't be so bad because the connection continues.
So ...
all this sounds very cool, very exciting,
and I wanted to see what is the current status
of those two protocols where we are going‑‑
how are we going, especially for this presentation,
I created the small site, which is‑‑
which has really cool name HTTPRulez.com,
it consists on the two pages, on the first
page we have‑‑ on the first page we
have.. it represents an online shop with CSS
JavaScript and images and the second page
I have a few web components, they are supposed
to be the future of web development, so I
wanted to see if we serve the content via
different protocols it will make some difference.
So ...
from my point of view that site is like Open
Source platform for testing different optimizations
strategies for HTTP 2.0, there is‑‑
this is the idea, same content, but, served
via different end points, via HTTP, HTTPS,
SPDY and HTTP 2, that's really cool, isn't
it?
I don't have QUIC end point yet, because there
is no production ready server, not this there
is HTTP 2.0 production server - I implemented
this on NodeJS, so I had to build version
of Node with ALPN support, but it currently
works.
On each page we can see the load time so we
can compare, and because we have great tools
like Webpage, now we can check what is the
difference‑‑ I intentionally did not
apply any of those dark workarounds we were
doing for years.
I did not create any sprite for images, there
are about 30 images, I did not create any
sprite, I wanted to start with something simple
and see how it behaves if we avoid all of
that.
On top we can implement further optimizations.
So, this is what HTT‑‑ what webpagepast
shows as waterfall when we use HTTPS, this
is the waterfall, you can see how it looks
like, you can also see that the browser Chrome
opened six connections for this domain and
now for each connection we have initializing,
we have SSL negotiation, which is expensive,
TCP needs three round trips, right, so this
is not so good.
Six connections, you can imagine how much
time we are losing for [establishing] all
those connections.
And here I have a waterfall, again with webpagetest,
which represents HTTP/2 waterfall without
server push.
On the server, I haven't pushed any of those
resources, I just relied on the browser to
do its best.
Currently this only works on Canary.
It doesn't work on Chrome, I hope in a few
months that it will be available in Chrome
too, but for now we have to use Canary and
apply a special flag - if you go to chrome://flags/
you is to enable SPDY/4 which is the internal
name of HTTP/2 for Canary.
But, now it works, it supports draft 14, which
is the latest one so that is really cool.
Here you can see that the browser created
only one connection to the server, not six,
this is the big deal.
All those resources were multiplexed and sent
to the browser via just one connection.
This is huge improvement.
But I wanted to see how it behaves if I push
some resources so here is the waterfall, what
currently webpagetest shows, probably that
will change because if you open Canary Dev
tools you can see all these resources, but
in webpagetest it looks like if the browser
made only one request to the server which
is index HTML or slash (/), but not - actually
I intentionally pushed all CSS, JavaScript
and images files when the browser requests
index HTML page.
So ...
again ...
we have connection view, it shows only one
connection, not six.
If we have to draw the line, I would like
to say the following:
If you remember the workarounds, which we
did to speed up our sites for years, all those
workarounds... ask yourself how HTTP 2.0 will
affect the way you develop and optimize web
applications for you or for your company.
Thank you very much (Applause)